WORLD LEADERS STRONGLY
CONDEMNING RUSSIA'S MISSILE
ATTACKS, EUROPEAN PARLIAMENTS
--
TWEETING, WHAT IS HAPPENING NOW
IN KYIV IS SICKENING.
IT SHOWS THE WORLD AGAIN, THE
REGIME WE ARE FACED WITH.
ONE THAT TARGETS
INDISCRIMINATELY.
ONE THAT REIGNS TERROR AND
DEATH DOWN ON CHILDREN.
THIS IS CRIMINAL.
THEY WILL BE HELD TO ACCOUNT.
UKRAINE WILL WEIGH, AND EUROPE
WILL NOT LOOK AWAY.
LET'S GET MORE FROM HARVARD AND
IT'S ALL.
ASHLEY JOINS ME NOW LIVE.
FROM BRUSSELS.
WOULD YOU SAY EUROPE MUST NOT
LOOK AWAY, AT THIS, POINT HOW
SHOULD EUROPE RESPOND?
YOU'VE SEEN THE CONSEQUENCE,
THE --
OF THESE ATTACKS ON UKRAINE,
INDISCRIMINATE SHELLING OF
CIVILIAN AREAS.
WHAT'S THE EUROPEAN RESPONSE?
>> WELL I THINK TODAY WAS ONE
OF THE TOUGHEST DAYS TO WAKE UP
TO WHERE WE SEE, AS YOU SAY,
THE IMAGES THAT WE SEE,
DISCRIMINATES --
OF WOMEN GOING ABOUT THEIR
DAILY LIVES.
THIS IS A CLEAR ESCALATION BY
PANICKED AUTOCRATS THAT HAS
GONE TO THE CAPITAL CITY OF A
COUNTRY THAT IS NOT ONLY
FIGHTING FOR ITS TERRITORY
INTEGRITY, BUT FIGHTING FOR THE
FUNDAMENTAL VALUES OF LIFE, OF
DEMOCRACY.
THIS IS ON OUR CONFIDENCE.
IT'S UP TO US TO RESPONSE.
WE HAVE ALREADY DONE A LOT WITH
SANCTIONS, IT'S CLEARLY NOT
ENOUGH.
UKRAINIANS ARE NOW ASKING FOR
MILITARY HELP, AND THE
PARLIAMENT STANDS WITH THAT.
--
WITH WHAT?
PUTTING SHOTS IN THE SKY?
WHAT IS THE RESPONSE?
PUTIN HAS CLEARLY IDENTIFIED
THAT HE HAS NO LIMITS AT THIS
POINT.
>> YOU ARE RIGHT.
FIRST OF ALL, WE NEED TO SEE
THE SANCTIONS PACKAGES THAT WE
HAVE ADOPTED, EIGHT SO FAR.
WHICH ONES ARE BINDING.
WHICH ONES NEED TO BE TOUGHER.
WHICH COUNTRIES ARE NOT
IMPLEMENTING THEM, AND THE
EUROPEAN PARLIAMENT HAS CALLED
FOR MORE MILITARY EQUIPMENT TO
BE DELIVERED TO UKRAINE.
UKRAINE'S VERY SPECIFIC DEMANDS,
WHETHER WE'RE ATTAINABLE,
THEY'RE WITH HEAVIER MILITARY
SYSTEMS.
THE MEMBER STATES HAVE THAT
EQUIPMENT.
THEY CAN COME TOGETHER AND
CONTRIBUTE WITH THE WEAPONS
THAT ARE NEEDED, IF THEY
COORDINATE.
THIS IS WHAT WE'RE ASKING FOR.
THEN NO ONE MEMBER STATES NEEDS
TO BE, LET'S, I HAVE A DENT IN
HIS MILITARY CAPACITY, WHICH IS
BEING QUESTIONED AND OTHER
GOVERNMENTS, IN OTHER
COUNTRIES.
ONCE WE HAVE THAT EQUIPMENTS,
WHY NOT DELIVER AID TO UKRAINE
FASTER.
IF ANYONE THOUGHT V T CASSETTE
N, AND WE COULD LOOK AWAY,
THESE IMAGES FROM TODAY, THE
CASUALTIES THAT WE SEE, HOW CAN
WE LOOK AWAY?
THOSE EUROPEAN PARLIAMENT IS
ONE THAT IS SAYING LET'S MAKE
SURE WE DO WHATEVER IT TAKES.
IF YOU HAVE ANSWERED, ONE OF
HUNDRED NOT START, HE CLEARLY
IS NOT SHOWING ANY SIGNS OF
STOPPING.
HOW ARE WE GOING TO RESPOND, IF
OUR RESPONSE IS NOT
PROPORTIONATE TO THE
ESCALATION.
THEN WE'RE JUST GOING TO BE
KILLING MORE PEOPLE.
>> LET'S BE QUITE CLEAR, I WANT
YOU TO EXPLAIN TO OUR VIEWERS
WHAT SORT OF TEETH THE EUROPEAN
PARLIAMENT HAS AT THIS POINT,
BECAUSE YOU'VE TALKED ABOUT
THAT ARE NOT IMPLEMENTING
SANCTIONS, WE TALKED ABOUT
COUNTRIES THAT AREN'T
CONTRIBUTING THE MILITARY
HARDWARE THAT UKRAINE NEEDS YES
AT PRESIDENT.
THESE ARE DECISIONS BEING MADE
BY EUROPEAN COUNTRIES THAT YOU
DON'T AGREE WITH.
YOU'RE TELLING THE EUROPEAN
PARLIAMENT DOESN'T AGREE WITH
THOSE DECISIONS.
WE'LL START CALLING THEM OUT.
WHAT ARE COUNTRIES DOING NOW
THAT THEY COULD DO MORE OF AT
THIS POINT?
WELL, THIS IS EXACTLY THE
POINT.
IF THERE ARE TANKS THAT ARE
OWNED BY MEMBER STATES, IF THEY
CAN BE DELIVERED TO UKRAINE,
LET'S BE ABLE TO DELIVER THEM.
WE HAVE ALREADY SHOWN
UNPRECEDENTED UNITY, BUT NOW WE
HAVE TO DO MORE.
THAT MEANS THAT WE SHOW
SOLIDARITY BETWEEN EACH OTHER,
BUT UKRAINE IS ASKING FOR OUR
HELP.
IF THEY ARE ASKING FOR TENANTS,
LET'S BE ABLE TO DELIVER THEM.
THAT IS SOMETHING CONCRETE THAT
CAN BE DELIVERED, THAT CAN BE
DONE.
MEMBER STATES COULD DO MORE AND
SHOULD DO MORE.
I THINK TODAY'S IMAGES ARE
TELLING US ABOUT THE ACTIONS
AND ARE SHOWING US TO NOT MAKE
THOSE MEMBER STATES GO CRAZY.
THIS PARLIAMENT IS MADE UP OF
--
WE ARE BEING TOLD BY OUR
CITIZENS TO DO MORE.
THAT IS OUR RESPONSIBILITY.
WE ARE ADOPTING DECISIONS FOR
QUICKER FINANCIAL ASSISTANCE TO
BE ARRIVING.
WE ARE TALKING FROM SOLIDARITY
ON THE GROUND PERSPECTIVE.
I AM IN CONSTANT CONTACT WITH
MY COUNTERPART, THE SPEAKER OF
THE UKRAINIAN FOUGHT --
TO ADD PEOPLE ON THE SANCTIONS,
GIVING MORE MONEY, AND
ULTIMATELY, AFTER TODAY, LET'S
GET MORE WEAPONS GIVEN TO
UKRAINE.
>> WHICH COUNTRIES SHOULD AND
COULD DO MORE?
CAN YOU BE CLEAR, PLEASE?
>> YES.
I THINK ALL COUNTRIES COULD AND
SHOULD DO MORE.
THERE ARE COUNTRIES WHICH HAVE
THE TANKS WHICH HAVE BEEN
IDENTIFIED BY UKRAINE.
LET'S SAY THAT THERE ARE 2000
TANKS WHICH ARE PRESENT IN THE
EUROPEAN UNION.
THAT CAN BE GIVEN.
A FEW OF THOSE SHOULD BE SENT
TO UKRAINE.
UKRAINE IS ASKING FOR THEM.
THE EUROPEAN UNION HAS THE
FACILITY TO COORDINATE WHAT IT
GIVES TO UKRAINE.
I KNOW THE REPRESENTATIVES ARE
VERY MUCH WORKING ON.
THAT WE CAN DO MORE IN THOSE
COUNTRIES.
I THINK WE WOULD SAY ALL THE
WAY FROM PORTUGAL TO ROMANIAN
CAN DELIVER THOSE WEAPONS THAT
ARE BEING ASKED FOR.
>> THE IMPACT THIS IS HAVING ON
EUROPEAN COUNTRIES --
GO ON.
>> THESE ARE COUNTRIES WHICH
HAVE ALREADY SHOWN UNITY.
THEY CAN CONTINUE TO DO THAT.
LET'S SAY I CONTINUE TO BE
ENCOURAGED BY THE UNITY.
>> THAT IS WHAT I WANT TO
PURSUE WITH YOU.
WE TALK A LOT ABOUT UNITY, BUT
TO THE EU COMMISSION PRESIDENT
HAS URGED FURTHER UNITY.
WE ARE HEADING INTO A --
>> TIME AND AGAIN, THE SINGLE
MARKET HAS PROVEN TO BE OUR
SINGLE BEST EFFORT IN TIMES OF
CRISIS.
THEREFORE, WE NEED TO PRESERVE
IT.
IT IS OF PARAMOUNT IMPORTANCE
THAT WE HAVE A LEVEL PLAYING
FIELD.
>> SHE IS CLEARLY CONCERNED
THAT EUROPE IS NOT PLAYING
TOGETHER AT PRESENT.
SHE HAS CONCERNS THAT IT WILL
NOT PLAY TOGETHER.
>> THAT IS EXACTLY WHAT PUTIN
WANTS.
I COMPLETELY AGREE WITH THE
PRESIDENT OF THE EUROPEAN
COMMISSION IN URGING MEMBER
STATES AND THEIR LEADERS TO
COME TOGETHER.
THERE IS AN INTEREST, LET'S SAY,
ON THE EXTREME FRINGES OF THE
POLITICAL SCENE THAT WOULD
ALIGHT THAT INSTABILITY TO BE
EXPLOITED.
WE IN THE EUROPEAN MARLMAN ARE
HERE TO TAKE DECISIONS IN ORDER
TO MAKE SURE THAT WHATEVER
HAPPENS, WHATEVER ASSISTANCE
YOU GET TO UKRAINE, ACTUALLY
DOES GET THERE.
WE WILL NOT BE THE ONES, LET'S
SAY, WAITING FOR OTHERS TO TAKE
THE DECISIONS BEFORE WE DO.
I WAS ENCOURAGED LAST WEEK --
THE BACKGROUND OF AN ENERGY
CRISIS.
THE PRIME MINISTER IS SAYING
THAT WE NEED TO GET OUR ACT
TOGETHER, TO COME TOGETHER, TO
SHOW THAT UNITY.
WHAT WE HAVE SEEN TODAY SHOWS
THAT RUSSIA WILL CONTINUE TO
ESCALATE FURTHER.
ARE WE READY?
THAT'S THE QUESTION TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE CAN RESPOND
PROPORTIONATELY TO.
I THINK THAT THAT IS A DAY WHEN
WE HAVE TO BE ABLE TO ANSWER
THE QUESTION.
OTHERWISE, NOT ONLY WOULD WE BE
DISAPPOINTING THAT UKRAINIANS,
BUT WE WOULD ALSO BE
DISAPPOINTING OUR CITIZENS.